new year same president Trump he woke up
early here in the nation's capital and
again was quickly setting the tone by
Twitter wishing a happy New Year to the
quote-unquote haters in fake news media
equipping that people suffering from
Trump derangement syndrome should just
sit back and enjoy the ride because he
said good things are happening he went
on to cheerlead the strong jobs market
he's presided over and tweeted out a
charge that Democrats are really for
open borders however the
commander-in-chief is facing a whole new
power dynamic in 2019 the partial
shutdown is well into its 11th day
there's still no end in sight as
Democrats prepare Thursday to officially
take control of the house and they hope
to quickly pass legislation to reopen
the government on their terms none of
the five billion dollars the president
is demanding for a border wall that may
be why the President did try a slightly
more diplomatic approach on Twitter by
the afternoon saying to Democrats
let's make a deal and the invited
congressional leader to come over
Wednesday to the White House which is
where we find our correspondent Kevin
cork good evening Kevin evening Edie a
stark new reality for the president and
the Trump administration this year
obviously as you pointed out a
Democratic controlled house to say
nothing of the ongoing government
shutdown partial shutdown but that will
not stop the president's plans for 2019
say White House officials nor apparently
will it stop his penchant for punching
opponents on Twitter if his New Year's
Twitter feed were a blockbuster film
president Trump's would have been a good
old-fashioned good cop bad cop movie
starring a president content to hammer
his so-called haters and all caps
chiding Democrats for ignoring all of
the crime and drugs that open borders
bring and at the very same time
showcasing his softer side even
suggesting to one of his chief
protagonists on Capitol Hill Nancy
Pelosi that the time might be ripe to
make a deal to end the government
shutdown and offer manifestly rejected
by the presumptive speaker who said the
president had given Democrat a great
opportunity to show how we will govern
responsibly and quickly pass our plan to
end the irresponsible hashtag Trump shut
down I'm ready to go they can come over
right now they could have come over any
time I spent Christmas in the White
House I spent New Year's Eve now in the
White House
and you know I'm here I'm ready to go
ready to go is one thing but willing to
compromise may yet be a bridge too far
particularly for president eager to Heil
border wall funding as the latest in a
string of Trump victories over the past
year including a successful Cavanaugh
confirmation to the Supreme Court record
low unemployment a new USMC a trade deal
to replace NAFTA the end of the Iran
nuclear deal and a dismantling of Isis
that seemed the Caliphate shrink
dramatically the latter of the courser
to other military moves in 2019
including a planned and precipitous
drawdown in Syria we're gonna get out
we're getting out of Syria we're
bringing our young great troops home
after so many years you know we were
supposed to be in Syria for three to
four months and that was four or five
years ago and it's time we have to bring
them home but few agenda items will be
accomplished this year including
movement on major infrastructure
legislation until the government reopens
putting the onus on the President and
congressional lawmakers to as the
president suggested make a deal or
suffer the political fallout while
everyday Americans suffer the
consequences
bit of housekeeping for you ad
congressional leaders have been invited
here to the White House to attend a
briefing by the Department of Homeland
Security on the border wall that
briefing set for 3:00 p.m. tomorrow
afternoon although sources tell our Chad
program it's unclear if they'll all make
it because of holiday travel we'll be
watching and waiting all the same back
to you Kevin cork live at the White
House thank you Kevin